just like mao chinese president xi
jinping is symbolically elevated to the
same status as the country's paramount
leader after the communist party passed
a rare resolution the document backs his
understanding of china's past and his
vision for china's future as she
consolidates his power at home there are
ongoing challenges in the region
speaking on the sidelines of the asia
pacific economic cooperation summit he
warned against provocation
attempts to draw ideological lines or
form geopolitical circles are bound to
fail the asia-pacific region cannot and
should not relapse into the
confrontation and division of the cold
war
for a view from taiwan now we're joined
by jejang lo a member of parliament
member of president tsai yangwen's
democratic progressive party mr lo
president xi is eyeing a third term and
ruler for life is not out of the
question and absorbing taiwan would be
legacy making for him how concerned are
you about a china that becomes even more
assertive
i think there's a growing concern in the
region you know indo-pacific region
about china's growing military power and
we do have concerns about uh the
possible military conflicts in the
taiwan strait
but
i don't think the war is imminent but
obviously we do have to prepare for the
worst case scenario
what do you say to observers who say
that perhaps the status quo is the best
option for taiwan
we've been trying to maintain the status
quo which is peace and stability in the
taiwan strait but there's a growing
military imbalance
in the taiwan state so we had to try our
best to maintain the delicate balance uh
with the hope that china would be
deterred from taking any reckless action
now there are reports that presidents
biden and xi will soon meet
virtually that is what are your
expectations for the americans here what
more do you want them to do
uh we are hoping that the us will be
more committed to the peace and static
stability in the region but we are
hoping that taiwan will not be put on
the table for negotiation but obviously
uh the u.s has also its own interest in
maintaining uh peace uh in the region so
we are not so concerned about uh
possible uh
you know sacrifice uh by the us
of taiwan
yeah certainly the americans do have an
interest in taiwan as a strategic
interest of course but do you really
think that the u.s will intervene
militarily should it come to that should
push come to shop i should say
but i think the u.s has been trying to
deter the prc from taking their military
actions so the first priority for us now
is try to
maintain the military capability and it
determines credibility in order to
prevent any war from happening
what more would you like to see joe
biden and the american administration
this american administration do for
taiwan
i think the military imbalance uh in the
region has been worrying a reason for a
lot of people in the region and also the
u.s commitment
to the peace and stability in taiwan and
in the region in general is also very
important so we are hopeful that the u.s
will be more committed and more
uh clear in its commitment to the
regional security
let's talk a little bit about
relationships um with european countries
do you get the sense that there's been a
slight shift perhaps in recent times
that some european nations appear to be
more willing to forge ties with with
your island
i'm very happy to see that the european
countries are now paying more attention
to the security development in the
region in the past people say that the
european countries only care about the
economic interest
in the indo-pacific but there's a
growing interest
on the part of the european countries on
the us on the security
development in the in the region and
we're also happy to see that there are
more military presence
by european countries including germany
france the uk and so on are in the
region
mr lowe this deepening engagement you're
certainly happy about it beijing is not
how concerned are you that this may
further provoke china
well china is expanding uh with or
without any so-called provocation by
other countries and i don't think we are
provoking china and tawa has every right
to maintain good relations with all
other like-minded countries including uh
european countries so i don't think that
we should be deterred uh by the plc from
uh improving our relations but obviously
uh china is expanding china is changing
from america or continental power uh to
a maritime power and uh for that uh
taiwanese has become more and more
important strategically so the
geostrategic importance of taiwan should
be uh be cherished by all the
democracies
taiwanese member of parliament jejang lo
thank you for joining us here on dw news
asia